- [Announcer] You've earned
this, so hold it up hot.
- We turn out to the Battle of the Beer,
as the Wall Street Journal reporting that
Modelo has overtaken Bud
Light as America's top beer.
- [Narrator] You may think Modelo
dethroned Bud Light after this.
- And Bud Light sent me possibly
the best gift ever, a can
on with my face on it.
- [Narrator] Led to this.
- The Bud Light boycott.
(gun firing)
- I'll serve you anything
except Bud Light.
- [Narrator] Well, that's partly true,
but it's not the whole story.
It's also thanks to this guy.
- I had the privilege
of being President
Obama's antitrust chief.
- [Narrator] He filed a lawsuit that
changed everything for the brand,
putting the imported
Mexican beer on the path
to take down the king of beers, Bud Light.
This is the Economics of Modelo.
- [Bill] It's a world
that changes all the time
but what's important never changes.
- [Narrator] But change came in 2012
when Anheuser-Busch InBev looked to
merge with Groupo Modelo.
the brewer of Modelo Especial, and Corona.
- I started at the Justice Department
in early January of 2013
and the biggest first matter
before me was an
investigation the staff had
into the effort by AB InBev to acquire
the worldwide rights to Modelo.
- [Narrator] That year, AB
InBev maker of Bud Light,
along with MillerCoors made up about 65%
of the US beer market.
- What our investigation found was that
every year InBev ABI and
MillerCoors would raise prices.
Modelo kept their prices stable,
and began to grow market share.
They were competing on the
merits and they were winning.
And it appears that AB InBev
didn't like that idea at all.
- [Narrator] So the
government's antitrust lawyers
advised the world's biggest beer maker
it'd have to sell the US
rights to Modelo Especial.
Before buying the company.
- We said, you need InBev
to completely divest
any interest in Modelo as it
relates to the United States.
They thought I was crazy and
I said, "Well, I may be crazy,
but if you don't agree to
that, we're gonna sue."
And they hemmed and
hawed, And so I sued them.
- [Narrator] After that,
AB InBev agreed to sell
the US rights to Modelo
Especial to Constellation.
A third beverage company that
mostly sold wine and spirits
but also imported Modelo
Especial to the US.
- We knew with them as an
independent owner of Modelo,
they'd have every incentive
to grow the brand,
maintain the quality,
introduce new brands,
incentives that InBev just
would not have had at all.
- [Narrator] Modelo and
its new parent company
had a long way to go
to dethrone Bud Light.
So Constellation began
looking at its marketing.
- It starts with creating
that universal broad appeal
across all types of consumers
and then expanding our investment
and moving into English language
and telling that story to more people.
- [Narrator] They launched a new campaign
running ads like this.
- [Announcer] Modelo,
the mark of a fighter.
- [Narrator] During live
multicultural sporting events
to reach new audiences.
- [Commentator] The fight clock
is brought to you by Modelo.
- [Narrator] Sales ticked upwards
as more people drank Modelo.
And that data was presented to retailers
using a Constellation program
called Shopper First Shelf.
- We do a lot of research
behind the scenes.
We lay out the optimal
flow of the beer aisle,
that will maximize retail
sales for the retailer
which then also helps
our distributor partners
and helps grow the overall beer category.
- [Narrator] They said
stores could increase sales
by arranging Modelo in a vertical line
with Corona to the left.
- What's interesting is Modelo
despite as big a brand as it is,
the brand awareness of Modelo is actually
much, much lower than of Corona Extra.
- [Narrator] The idea was that consumers
would see Corona first
and then intuitively
look to the right and find Modelo.
They also recommended that Modelo
be shelved in the refrigerators.
Since most imported beer is purchased
to be consumed within six hours.
So shoppers needed it cold.
Inside the refrigerators,
Constellation recommended
it be placed at eye level
and near the door handle.
To maximize visibility,
they found beers that moved
from hinge to handle position
increased sales by 8%.
- Modelo Especial has enjoyed
really high velocities
for a long time.
When we have really high
velocities, what's important is
that we get enough space on the shelf
so that we have enough inventory
so the shelf isn't empty.
- [Narrator] Constellation
pushed retailers
for more shelf space for Modelo because
it was selling so quickly, sales rose.
By the end of the 2021 calendar year,
Modelo Especial had passed
AB InBev's Michelob Ultra
to land the number two spot
by retail store dollar sales.
That jump was partially fueled
by a push to shift Modelo's consumer base.
- In the 2019 fiscal year,
Modelo's consumers were
about 70% Hispanic.
- [Narrator] And that
population has been growing
helping to drive sales.
- But Constellation was really pushing to
give the brand a mass market appeal.
- [Narrator] It worked,
now about 45% of Modelo's
consumer base is non-Hispanic.
Both have driven more market share.
With all of that growth,
analysts projected that Bud Light
was on track to lose
its top spot to Modelo
as early as 2024.
But they probably didn't
anticipate Bud Light sales
falling as dramatically as they did.
Anheuser-Busch says Bud
Light's US market share
has stabilized and that
it will win back drinkers
by staying away from controversial topics.
Since the boycott, the company has worked
on new Bud Light ads like this,
emphasizing ties to
football and country music.
♪ In a radio world ♪
AB InBev also said, let's not forget
millions of people still
choose Bud Light each day
and year to date Bud Light remains
number one in volume sales.
- Modelo's Rise is really
the result of changing demographics,
changing consumer tastes,
and savvy marketing
on the part of Constellation.
And then to sort of top it all off,
this Bud Light boycott
blew it out of the water.
- We expected we would be in this position
maybe a year or two from now.
So it did happen a little
bit earlier than expected
but it's a great place to be.
But what we're focused on now is how
do we maintain this
position going forward?
- Now Modelo is on track to have greater
dollar sales for the full year of 2023.
So it looks to be solidifying its place
as the top beer in America.
- To give the American consumer choice
is what competitive markets is all about,
and it's up to
Constellation to keep going.
They clearly have the momentum and
and the consumer demand on their side.
(upbeat music)